5 16 on your Wednesday morning what's
cool at school how about building models
of imaginary cities of the future to
help solve the problems of today
that's exactly what happened this past
weekend at the North Las Vegas campus of
the College of Southern Nevada where
dozens of middle school students wrapped
up months of hard teamwork by making
presentations to panels of Judges from
engineering fields
without from their teachers and
volunteer mentors they all found
different ways to tackle this year's
future city competition issue climate
change and the climate change issue that
we chose to do was controlling flooding
so our city actually raises up
physically on our model and in our city
the Butterfield model from Seville
Middle School one of the four that made
it to the final round along with teams
from Fast Middle School the Las Vegas
day school and the winner a team called
Shahar Savers from Hyde Park Middle
School
so those Hyde Park students now go on to
represent Nevada at the National Future
City competition next month in
Washington D.C good luck Panthers you
know we always want to know what's cool
at school if you got something let us
know cool at school under the Community
tab of our website or just email cool at
school at 8newsnow.com and as you
mentioned John all those kids are using
recycled stuff from around the house for
empty plastic bottles or whatever but
the engineering principles that they
learn from their volunteer mentors I
mean these kids are like genius talking
about how to solve flooding hey just
have your city raise up so the water
goes down